another big transition day for the clark  kennedy school district coming up  tomorrow  most staff returning to buildings after  a year of distance education  it's part of the preparation to welcome  back some students in grades 6  9 and 12. that's next monday for the  start of hybrid learning  a high school educator we spoke with  expects to see a moment  frozen in time when he steps back in the  classroom  we'll see the date from last year up on  my board  i will see my my objectives and lesson  plans  and just things about school dances or  whatever from last year  so yeah very much so i i think it's  going to be  a trip back into uh the past  will be kind of odd right well some  teachers say receiving the covet 19  vaccine  also eases their worries about going  back